All of our examples so far have
involved functions, g of
x, that are monotonic in
X, at least over the
range of x's of interest.
Let us now look at an example
that involves a
non-monotonic function.
We're going to consider the
square function, which has the
shape shown in this diagram.
And we'll assume that X has a
general distribution so that
it can take both positive
and negative values.
And so over the range of values
of X, the function that
we're dealing with is
decreasing and then
increasing.
So it is not monotonic.
How can we find the
distribution of Y?
As a warm-up, let's look
at the discrete case.
And as an example of the
calculation, let us find the
formula for the probability
that the random variable Y
takes a value of 9.
This event can happen
in two ways.
It can happen if X
is equal to 3.
But it can also happen if x
is equal to negative 3.
And these are the two and only
two ways that y can take a
value of 9.
We can generalize this
calculation.
The probability that the random
variable y takes on a
specific value little y, this
probability can be found by
adding the probabilities of all
of the different x's that
lead to this particular value.
Now, for X squared to be equal
to little y, we need to have X
to be equal either to the
positive square root of y or
to be equal to the negative
square root of y.
And this is the general formula
for the PMF of the
random variable Y. And it
involves two terms, because
any given value of little y can
happen in two ways, either
by having X equal to the
negative square root of y or
by having X be equal to the
positive square root of y.
We have here a situation where
the function that we're
dealing with is not
invertible.
For a given value of y, we
cannot find a single value of
x that will lead to that y.
But instead, we typically have
two values of x that lead to
that particular y, namely the
positive and the negative
square roots of y.
So we cannot use the tools that
we used before in the
monotonic case, where we dealt
with the inverse function.
What we can do instead is to
proceed from first principles
and calculate the CDF of the
random variable Y. The CDF of
Y is the probability that the
random variable is less than
or equal to a certain number.
And we're going to focus only on
the case where that certain
number is non-negative.
If little y is negative, then we
know that this probability
is going to be 0, because the
random variable Y cannot take
negative values.
Now, this is the probability
that the random variable X
squared is less than
or equal to y.
So what we did here is to
express this event in terms of
the original random variable,
capital X, whose PDF is
presumably available.
Now, this event is the same as
requiring the absolute value
of X to be less than or equal
to the square root of y.
And this event, again, is the
same as having the random
variable X be between the
negative and the positive
square root of y.
In terms of a picture, the
random variable capital Y
takes a value less than or
equal to this particular
little y if and only if the
random variable x falls inside
this range.
Now, we want to express this
probability in terms of the
CDF of X. The probability that
we're looking at, the
probability of this interval,
is equal to the probability
that x is less than or equal
to the square root of y.
This is the probability from
minus infinity up to the
square root of y.
But from this, we need to
subtract the probability of
this interval.
And that would be the CDF of
the random variable x up to
the point [negative]
square root of y.
So we now have an expression for
the CDF of Y in terms of
the CDF of X. At this point,
now we can take derivatives
and use the chain rule.
The PDF of Y is going to be
equal to the derivative of
this expression.
The derivative of the first
term, by the chain rule, is
the PDF of X, evaluated at the
square root of y times the
derivative of this argument with
respect to y, which is 1
over 2 square root of y.
And then we need the derivative
of the second term.
We have a minus sign, then
the derivative of the CDF
which is the PDF.
Evaluate it at minus
square root of y.
And then the derivative of this
term with respect to y,
which is minus 1 over two
square root of y.
Now, we have a minus sign here
and a minus sign there.
So the two cancel out.
We can get rid of this minus 1
term and change this minus
into a plus.
And this is the final
form of the answer.
So we see that the PDF of Y
evaluated at a particular
point, which tells us
something about the
probability that the random
variable takes values around
this point, has to do with the
probabilities that the random
variable X takes values around
here or around there.
There are two contributions, and
this is because there are
two different ways that a value
of y may occur, either X
falling here or X
falling there.